the human population has to be kept at a
certain level for the Ideal Balance
Plato's whole system was based on
Pythagoras's number mysticism and so
there's a lot of hoodoo in that but what
what today's Elite have borrowed or
taken from Plato isn't the idea of
dialectics and part of dialectics is
that you have to do evil and good at the
same time yeah he also believed in
problem reaction Solution that's where a
lot of the larger kind of uh um
implementation of a lot of different
programs that they do Plato thinks that
Society should be controlled by a secret
society that lies to the public it's
called The Noble lie and it's a it's a
loose kind of technocratic model even
though he didn't believe it they didn't
know about technology per se and the way
that we do
in Plato's Republic you have discussions
of techne which is the same idea the
whole idea is that Society should be run
like a giant math program